they saw how the ratings jumped for the
ESPYs this year and part of the reason
was Caitlin so it only makes sense she
showed up on the show nischelle Turner
back because it's time to talk ESPYs bad
yes we gotta talk ESPYs fashion now
Kevin look I know you're a sports guy
you love sports office put it like this
I like that the fashion was a home run
and you're good at it cuz you look good
today yeah now listen we got the secrets
behind Caitlyn's look straight from her
stylist who has worked for magic with
Angelina Jolie the fashion police oh
please be kind on me I'm new at this but
anyway the look that Caitlin was going
for was definitely old Hollywood glamour
something very chic classic and
sophisticated Kate and I for inspiration
shared pictures one was a vintage
picture of Lauren Bacall I've never felt
more pressure than I ever had felt in my
life then over the last couple of months
picking out this outfit okay girls I get
it
you got to get the shoes the hair the
makeup the whole process it was
exhausting even if she was really
nervous she was just enjoying it I feel
like she was really taking it all in you
know enjoying getting hair done enjoying
the make up the process she was super
excited Jen told us 10 swatches of
custom dyed ivory were considered before
finally setting on Caitlin's Atelier
Versace creation the ruched v-neck was
reminiscent of gowns Caitlin wore in her
Vanity Fair photo shoot a look that
seems to suit her long lean frame
Donatella was over the moon I mean that
would be like an understatement she was
so honored she was so excited it didn't
even take a half a second and they were
like yes yes yes we're in yes the final
dress was the result of two separate
look sent from the designer the top and
bottom put together by gin and Caitlin
and then Kate came over with the lil
roll of scotch tape and we just taped
the two together and then I took a
picture and sent it back to Versace and
said you know this is what we're
thinking Caitlin added a pair of three
thousand four hundred fifty dollar
vintage emerald drop earrings by Bella
Dora to her look which was contrasted by
her family in all black Kim Khloe
Kourtney Kendall and Kylie could all be
seen in the audience in an emotional
show of support letting Caitlyn shine
you